الممثله جوري بكر متصدر الترند خلال
الايام الماضيه جوري هي وداد زوجه اخوه
لجعفر العمده اللي هو سيد وداد في المسلسل
شرير وقادره وبتخطط وبتحييك المكائد هم من
وقت ما تم عرض الحلقه 18 من مسلسل والناس
قايمه قيامته وغضبانه من جوري بسبب مفاجاه
مو متوقعينه واللي هي زواجها من عدو عائله
زوجها وخلعها لزوجها سيد من غير ما يعرف
والمشهد هذا بالذات قلب الدنيا على راسه
وداد او جوري في المسلسل والواقع كمان
وكاتن جوري شاركت الفيديو وقالت سامحني يا
سيد انت ونعيم سامحوني يا عيله جعفر
العمده
وليه قلت لكم قلب الدنيا على راسه وداد في
الواقع لانه ببساطه ردات الفعل من متابعي
المسلسل على المشهد فاقد التوقعات
اما جوري فكانت شافت رداد الفعل ويبدو
انها تاثرت فيها ونشرت ستوري من ايام قالت
فيها ان هذا التمثيل وطلبت من متابعين
مسلسل انه يتوقفوا عن السب والشتيمه وانه
هذا الشيء بياذيها نفسيا
ومعنى من القاهره الفنانه جوري بكر اهلا
فيك معانا يا جوري يعني انت ترند صار لك
كم يوم في كل الوطن العربي
الحمد لله اهلا بك يا ساره وشكرا جدا على
الاستضافه الجميله دي جدا
وما شاء الله العمل محقق نجاح يعني كبير
بس يعني خلينا نقول انه الناس معصبه من
شخصيتك جدا جدا جدا جدا جدا جدا جدا يعني
الموضوع وصل انك انت تقولي للناس بس كفايه
شتيمه ايش صار
دي حقيقه فعلا انا ما كنتش متوقعه ان انا
هبقى مستفزه قوي كده غير لما شفت نفسي على
الشاشه انا شخصيا كرهت كرهت الشخصيه كرهت
وداد جدا يعني حتى اللي حواليا كلهم حرفين
كرهوها
بس يعني لما نقي ايش صار لك ايش يعني انت
جاتك اتصالات ولا على السوشيال ميديا وين
كان السب يعني والشتيمه والتهديد
السب والشتم ابتدا من على السوشيال ميديا
ناس كتير جدا وناس يمكن حرفيا قريبين مني
كانوا بيشتموا او بيحاسبنه بيقولوا حاجات
صعبه جدا انا يمكن علشان يعني
النجاح المفروض ان اللي حصل ده نجاح
والمفروض ان انا اتقبل الموضوع ده بس انا
يمكن عشان لسه يعني عشان لسه انا جوايا
انا كجوري وبتصرف ان انا كجوري وخلاص خلصت
المسلسل ده فبقول انتوا بحس الشتايم دي او
السب ده او الاهانات دي كلها بتضرني انا
او بتضر الناس المتابعين ليا سواء اهلي او
او زوجي او اصدقائي اللي حواليا انه
يشوفوا كلام جارح على صوره من صوري فحسيت
ان الكلام ثقيل هم قالوا لي احنا مش بنكره
جوري احنا بنكره فعلا شخصيه وداد تستاهل
كل كلمه اتقالت عليها طب انت عروسه جديده
جوري طبعا يعني مبروك بس انه
ايش راي زوجك في وداد
هو انا متاكده وانا متاكده ان جوزي حاليا
قاعد على الكنبه في البيت بيتفرج على
الحلقه عايزه اقول لك ان هو مبسوط جدا
بالمسلسل فخور بيا بيدعمني من اول يوم
اشتغلت فيه في المسلسل بس هو خايف مني
اوكي كان دايما يقول يا جوري اوعي تعملي
فيا زي ما بتعملي في سيد فبقول له لا هو
طبعا حاجه تانيه خالص وبشكره طبعا ان هو
اداني اجازه انزل مصر كم يوم علشان احتفل
بنجاحي وسبته قاعد في كسر لوحده بس يعني
ان شاء الله ربنا يجمعنا مع بعض بس يعني
هو اوفر اويل هو عارف ان جوري ملهاش اي
علاقه بوتات هو عارف ان انا طيبه جدا
يعني كنا نحتاج ناخذ منه مداخله يا جوري
يمكن عنده راي مختلف هو الان بعيد عنك
يعني يمكن يقول كلام ثاني على العموم احنا
جايين نهدي النفوس يعني ما تقلقيش لنا
زياره قريب لينا زياره قريبه ان شاء الله
طب بس من الاساس انت يعني كيف اختارك محمد
سامي لهذا العمل تحديدا هذا الدور
الموضوع ده صدفه بحته جدا انا كنت موجوده
في العرض الخاص مع استاذه مي عمر فتقريبا
هو كان بيدور على الشخصيه دي او يمكن كان
في حد مكاني واعتذر عن الدور فمي استاذه
مي قالت له محمد انا شايفه ممكن جوري تبقى
حلوه جدا في الدور ده وفعلا كلمني استاذ
محمد وقال لي جوري انا عندي دور مهم جدا
وايه رايك قلت له طبعا انا اكيد مع حضرتك
يعني استاذ محمد سامي استاذ محمد رمضان
اكيد مسلسل هيكسر الدنيا ايوه وفعلا هو
لقى كسر الدنيا بس لما قرات الورق بعدين
اتوقعتي حجم الكراهيه اللي حتواجهيها
لا للاسف يا ساره لا خالص عارفه لما كنت
بقرا الورق وبمثل اللي انا شفته على
التلفزيون ولما نزلت الشارع يا نهار ابيض
ما كنتش حاسه ان هي وحشه قوي كده على
الحقيقه في التلفزيون لازم يعني ما شاء
الله النجاح الكبير صارت الناس جالسه
بتفتش وبترجع وبتدور طبعا على اعمالك
وبيقرا وكذا ومش عارفه ايش بيدخلوا
مقابلاتك والكلام ده كله وصار كتير ناس
بيقولوا انك انت حفيده الفنانه الراحله
الكبيره ماري منيب وشاروا بيحطوا لكم صور
مع بعض والكلام ده كله بس اظن عندنا حتى
يعني ان احنا صوره ايوه الان صور الان
ظاهره على الشاشه لكم انت من العمل كاداه
وماري منيب طبعا غنيه عن التعريف يعني
الله يرحمها بس توضحي لنا هل فعلا في
بينكم قرابه
اتمنى ده يزيدني شرف لا طبعا بس انا كنت
بحب حركات وشها وانا بحبها جدا وكنت فعلا
بقلدها شويه في مشاهد عشان كده طلعت يعني
كوبي بايست اوكي كنت عندك بتسوي في شفايفك
يمكن كنت حركات قريبه من حركات شفايفها
كمان
الشخصيه كويس جدا على فكره ايوه طب الان
ما تخافي يا جوري انه بعد النجاح هذا كله
الكبير انه الناس تحصرك في هذا النوع من
الادوار
هذا اللي انا خايفه منه بس يعني ان شاء
الله لا وانا يمكن دلوقتي الفتره اللي
جايه اقدر ان انا اختار الادوار بعنايه
كويسه يعني واقدر اقرا واشوف انا ايه اللي
هيليق عليا وايه اللي مش هيليق عليا بس
ممكن يكون ادوار شعبيه او ادوار بنت فلاحه
او ادوار سعديه انا بحب الادوار اللي هي
بتاعه بنات البلدي بحب الادوار القويه بس
ما يكونش ما يكونش محصوره في وداد اكون
محصوره ممكن في حاجه شبه الشخص زي محمد
رمضان مثلا ما معظم مسلسلات وبتناشد
الشارع او البيوت المصريه كلها من من
البيوت الصغيره ومن الطبقات الصغيره لاكبر
طبق طبقه موجوده عندنا في البلد انا بحب
يعني انا بحب طريقته في الشغل واتمنى ان
انا كمان على المستوى النسائي ابقى زيه
يعني في نفس زي شغله طب لما الان انت
بتقولي انك انت متزوجه وقاعده في قطر
والكلام هذا كله بعض الناس بيقولوا انه
هذا يمكن ياثر على مسيرتك يعني الفنيه انه
لا ما راح يفرق يعني
دي حقيقه وعايزه اقول لحضرتك كمان ان هو
اصلا واحنا في الكواليس واحنا عارفين انه
تمثيل هم كانوا كارهني فعلا وكنت بخاف
يعني انا كنت بصور الاتجاه ده هم الاتجاه
التاني انا كنت بخاف اعدي الشارع اروح لهم
من كتر ما هم تعبانين ومخنوقين وبيعيطوا
بجد وعايشين الشخصيه يعني من جوه قلبهم
متقمصين الدور جدا والله كنت بخاف وبالذات
استاذه هاله صدقي انا كنت استحاله اقرب
ناحيتها وانا عدوه وانا عدوه استحاله كانت
هتقتلني الملكه صفصف طبعا يعني هم صفصف
طبعا كان نفسهم يجيبوا لي من شعري هي حتى
كانت بتقول استاذ محمد هو احنا ينفع نروح
نضربها ونجيبها من شعرها ونخلص من المشهد
ده
طيب ربنا ربنا انقذك ههه على العموم احنا
بنتمنى لك التوفيق الحمد لله وان شاء الله
من نجاح لنجاح يا جوري كانت معنا عبد
القاهره الفنانه جوري بكر شكرا لك اشكرك
[موسيقى]